hello everybody
here we are live
december q a
so i hope everybody is doing well
and uh that you're having happy holidays
despite the insanity which continues to
progress
and so as some of you know we are
changing the format of the q a
just because at some point you know we
sorry let me just do this
we uh
at some point there was too many
questions and so i was not even
paying attention to the chat i stopped
taking uh
super chats um and so at some point it
was like why am i doing this live for in
for the public because
there doesn't seem to be any reason why
i would be doing that
and so instead what we're going to do
from now on is this is going to be
only uh streaming live only for people
that are supporting me somehow on
patreon
and uh then we'll make it public later
but hopefully what that means is that
i'll be able to interact with the chat a
little more
than usual and there'll be less madness
less chaos
nonetheless brad is in the chat and so
and lisa's there as well which means
that even though there's only 12 people
watching we don't we will not stand for
any chaos and so
all right so it's just yeah so i'm
feeling i'm feeling a little spry
despite the
madness here in quebec
as some of you may know they are
asking for coveted passports to go to
church now
and so yeah so we are going reaching
another level here
yeah all right all right and so a few
announcements
um
my prediction for 2022 if you want to
hear it it's gonna keep going nothing's
gonna change much it's gonna get
uh worse i would think
because
the uh the measures that have been put
in place in the past two years are going
to look more and more political
and uh they are going to um
gonna just be a slow burn into
into uh surveillance
basically a surveillance state so
that's my uh that's my prediction for
2022 so sorry to uh disappoint you if
you're hoping that i was going to bring
you some good news
so brad says when the world goes mad
rokkor is on the rock
yeah yeah we know that feeling you know
i think i do think and i have to say and
i might make some people in the
different hierarchies mad when i say
this but i do think that the manner in
which people deal with
the pandemic
and the way people deal with the
measures that are coming right now
that will decide the health of the
church to a certain extent and those
churches
which um
favor communion
uh will do much better than those
that favor
that favor safety and also favor um
just falling in line with whatever we
are asked to do
so anyways so enough of that enough
getting in trouble
so let's go let's do this
all right so i will start with the
website and i will try to look into the
uh the the chat and answer a few
questions in the chat for example could
you explain chinese time that's no let's
start with someone in chat there you go
i feel free to do that stop maxineo asks
could you explain the headless horseman
symbolically
i mean i
th the the headless horseman has to do
of course with
let's say moving towards the the
solstice you know it's like the losing
of the head the losing of meaning which
happens in winter when things start to
die and so that's what losing the head
is you know
and especially a horseman it's basically
just this kind of wild potential that
has lost its reason lost its purpose and
can act out of vengeance can act out of
all kinds of things which are more on
the dark side
um so that's the headless horse of means
and it makes sense that he would appear
let's say on halloween and haunt the
world as the world is getting darker and
the sun is going down
all right
all right so here we go so we're gonna
start with the website as usual oh no
last this is the last uh need to make
this last announcement i guess is that
today actually tomorrow is going to be
the last day
for the gods dog crowdfunding it has
been an amazing ride we are probably
going to reach 200 000
and uh we have like 3 300 backers which
means that uh all the stretch goals have
been attained people are gonna get
posters people are gonna get uh um
everybody's gonna get a copy pdf copy of
the uh the secrets of god's dog which
will have some articles from me on saint
christopher some sketches from our
original designs and the greatest thing
that's going to be in there is going to
be an article that metsyra is furiously
working on right now it'll be the first
thing that he's published since his book
and so if you haven't gotten on board
today and tomorrow is the time to do
that to get on board with god's dog uh
so that's been a lot of fun
that's been a lot of fun all right so
here we go
so we start with the website
and so david flores asks
there's a story about a foreign king
that visits saint simion the stylites
and simeon has been wounded in the leg
and worms fall from the wound the king
picks it up and it turns into a pearl
is the worm which is of little value to
send simeon a precious gift to someone
at a lower level of being because he is
higher up or is there more to this
symbolism that i am missing there is
definitely
more to this symbolism that you were
missing and i'm happy that you stumbled
upon that story because it's a pretty
amazing story um
and uh
it's basically what christianity is
about if you want to understand this
story it's what i've talked about in
terms of the relationship
between the crown of thorns and the
crown of glory it's an exact it's a very
discreet example of the transformation
of death into glory
and how there's a relationship between
death and glory depending on
let's say the difference between
accidental death and willful death
or you know conscious dying to oneself
rather than being a slave to death so
here is the example which is that saint
simian basically lives a a life of dying
a constant life of dying
to
the extent that he doesn't notice and
part of the story is that he doesn't
even care he doesn't care that he has
basically has like these worms that are
rotting in his flesh his flesh is almost
like a living it's almost like a rotting
flesh and the worms are falling to the
ground
and they become pearls they become
uh they become seeds they become glory
for you know
images of glory um and so it's related
to uh relics the symbolism of relics
and uh it's a very it's a very difficult
symbolism for people to
understand but it's a it's very concise
especially in that story it's very very
concise
um
and it's so it is mysterious how that
happens but that's what said simeon
is about
all right so cormac jones asks have you
thought have you any thoughts on the
symbolism of linear perspective in art
what does it mean to view space
this way
um
and so i think that
there's something about linear
perspective in art which can be somewhat
useful
in the sense that it can make you notice
um this perspective because in a way
it's like the re it's a side effect and
kind of the reverse of the sense that
you're standing here and you're looking
out at the world and so you have these
these lines or these rays that go out
and and uh
let's say that you that makes to help
you encounter things in space and so
linear perspective
can be a reflection of that
and so you could have this so you've
read probably read the idea of how it's
basically like this infinite recession
in the back and so it can help you kind
of understand a the point of attention
let's say and how it structures the rest
all of that is makes sense um but
there's also a darker side let's say to
linear perspective which is a kind of uh
solidification
and freezing of experience you know
um and also the weird kind of
the weird god's eye view the weird
abstracted view that the modern world uh
um seems to
be related to linear perspective as well
you know the thing i criticized when i
and i say that people aren't aware of
what where they are like where are when
i say things like where are you when you
say that you know there's a sense in
linear perspective where
that is also um
yeah that that's also kind of lost
but that's very intuitive intuition on
my part
all right so cftr
ask is the ongoing disappearance of the
female hidden space
one of the reasons why we have
increasing trouble
finding understanding and forgiveness
the changing of minds often only happens
in the hidden space this is hard to do
when our nervous system is extended and
exposed to the world via the internet
that's for sure
that is for sure because
there's also a sense in which when we
are in public you know there are all
these other factors which come into the
come into question
um
and um
and you're right that changing your mind
and forgiveness happens in a kind of
stillness that's why you never see
anybody change their mind during a
debate as if that's ever gonna happen
that's why i don't like debates very
much you know whatever they're fine you
know but but they're they're usually for
the people watching not for definitely
not for the people debating
um and so yes i just definitely agree
um
all right so arose says 77 are the four
living creatures of revelation the
angels of the four gospels yes they are
definitely related to the angels of the
four gospels they are the four faces of
the cherub right the four living beings
all of these the four aspects of
divinity
the four yeah the four manifest aspects
of divinity and so that's why they're
related to the gospels the the original
notion of the four creatures comes from
the book of ezekiel where you know you
have these chairs with four faces
um but then this of course has also its
version in the four creatures
in uh in revelation
all right so stephen
all right so i uh so stephen wong says
hi jonathan i read your article the
samaritan woman baptism and the hexagon
that article article you mentioned the
samaritan woman at the well is related
to baptism
but i don't quite understand that can
you explain why she is related to
baptism
well she's this is she's related to
baptism because she's the waters
she is the she's an aspect of the
chaotic waters you could say
and so
there are two there are two aspects of
the waters below there there's an aspect
of the waters which is something like
uh
purity
of of the lower waters there's also an
aspect of the lower waters which are
something like the salt waters the
bitter waters the saturated waters okay
and so the
so the the samaritan woman represents
what you could call the saturated waters
because she's had
all these men
you know
and
she's had six husbands
you know
she's had five this her sixth husband is
illegitimate
and now christ appears as her seventh
husband the one that brings her
um
that brings her the water of life you
know and this water of life is the water
of baptism
and it's it's related to sabbath it's
related to the seventh day in the sense
that it has also to do with death and
with rest
right the the sabbath is the day that
christ is in the tomb all these images
kind of come together
and so often that's why often in
the
in the icon of the samaritan woman the
shape of the baptismal font
is a cross
there are different versions of it and
but sometimes it's a cross because
ancient baptismal fonts were in the
shape of a of a cross or like the four
directions basically and then the water
the water there in the
in in this this kind of uh that's a
cross
light on its side let's say
and so that's why the samaritan woman is
related to baptism
i hope that makes sense
so yeah and you can also understand it
like in an interesting way because
uh
this is gonna flip your mind sorry i i
guess i have to do it which is that
she's giving christ the lower waters
she's saying she's bringing up these
lower waters and she's wanting to give
them and then christ is saying i'm gonna
offer you the water from above
you know and so there's a scent in which
the joining of the higher waters and the
lower waters
that's the flood that's the that's the
flood by the way that's that's uh
that's death you know but it's also the
change into it's also like a kind of
purification which brings about a new
world and so when christ when the lower
waters and the higher waters join
together it's also the joining the
creating of a new world and so this this
imagery that christ is bringing
is as old as
as like the imagery of like tiamat
the the the dragon of the salt water the
dragon of fresh water joining together
and creating the word that's how old the
imagery that christ is invoking here is
and so so it's a very very powerful
story the story of the samaritan woman
we often we offer we have to be always
really careful not to be uh
not to be tricked by the simplicity of
the gospel stories
um
and then also uh the the samaritan
woman's saint futini you know you see
her she also like gets thrown into a
well like her whole story if you read
the story as a saint it's constantly
related to the well so the well is is
all about what uh saint fortini is about
and the well is also
an image of uh
of baptism
so
all right okay so luka skovic asks i'm
working on my master's degree
the thesis is on the structure of the
icon of the last judgment
what literary sources would you
recommend for this work
i'm not gonna lie the main inspiration
for this work is your last judgment
video
on the
lord of spirits podcast
uh and the lord spirit podcast uh that's
fine um
um
to be honest
like i said i don't i don't have a lot
of literary work i've been working on
the icon of the last judgment myself
for a very long time for like 20 years
and studying it and writing about it so
i've written several um
several articles about it
some of them which i haven't published
some of them which i actually did as
in courses on iconography and university
um so
i wish it could help you there there are
there isn't a lot around you have to you
have to parse it out yourself figure it
out and uh you know you can discover
what the elements in the icon is are and
then from there you can work from there
so good luck with that
um
so josh the mover asks is there deeper
significance
to there being three different marys of
the crucifixion or is it purely
happenstantial could a deeper
significance apply to other instances of
several different people appearing with
the same name
um
um
all right and so
the idea
it the idea of mary the multiple marries
i think is very important
and i think that some of it some of that
symbolism seemed to be a little lost to
us
um but there seems to be something
related to how mary
the lord this idea of the difference
between the
let's say the mary with the pure mary
and the saturated mary and so let's say
mary the mother of god as the pure
virgin
and let's say mary magdalene from whom
christ uh exercised uh demons what is it
seven demons or something and so the
difference between those two if you're
interested in that i wrote an article on
um
on the different symbolism of the the
different women in the church and so
there's a in the tradition you end up
having mary the mother of god
and then mary the egyptian mayor said
mary of egypt in the orthodox church and
in the catholic church it's really the
mary the mother of god and then
mary magdalene and all the legends that
that appear around her about her being a
prostitute and all that which is not in
scripture but is but it's kind of like
this this the the different the
saturated mary right the
the difference between the the pure mary
and the saturated mary
and so
that's what that's the seems to be the
symbolism that a lot of these marries
are playing
in uh in the in the gospel but it's hard
to totally kind of get it especially
with the three mary's like what's the
third one she like that is she the
joining of the two uh maybe not sure not
sure all right
um let's see in the chat
so frederick gopher schmidt says how do
you know if it's god you're worshiping
and not an angel or or
mother mary
um
well it's just i mean
it's the name you're right you know
the names of things are related to the
things you when you call upon things you
call upon things by their name
and so if you're calling upon
the divine trinity the father son and
the holy spirit if you're calling upon
christ if you're calling upon the father
then you're not worshiping
other things you're worshiping god um
i mean i know that sound maybe maybe
sound a little there are moments when we
are understanding of god is lower and so
sometimes
i've mentioned this before where
you know you
you're worshiping god but in your but
really let's say in practice you are
attending to god as if god was a lower
aspect as if god was an angel or was
these different things
and i think that's kind of inevitable
but i also think that you know
that's what grace is for right grace is
there to kind of pull us up through
through the steps you know it's a lie in
spiritual life is a pro is progress and
it's a uh it's a transformation so you
can't
pierce the divine mystery of the
infinite you know uh source of all being
at the outset that doesn't doesn't work
that way
um
and so someone says it's a shame you
skipped my concern over the nft use
so i will address the nft thing
um i'm thinking maybe we could do that
now if someone
wants to let me see
i was sent the question let me find it
all right
all right so david
marcum says
says do you think it's possible to wade
into the flood in order to piss in it
without getting wet and raising the
water level yes i'm talking about god's
dog nfts and so well david first thing
is thanks for making me swear that's
always appreciated
not sure it was necessary but that's
okay
um
so let's let's look at we need to look
at this a little uh a bit in a wider
understanding we have to look at it in
terms of god's dog the project in itself
now
the way you phrase your question is very
fascinating because
you know the story of saint christo
christopher is about a monster going
into the water right
you know that that's the story the story
of saint christopher is about a monster
going into the
into the flood that's what's actually
the story is about and the idea is that
for some reason
saint christopher is able to carry
the child
across the waters and
no you can't do that without getting wet
and
and i think that
i think that maybe this is important to
understand that
a lot of the stuff that i'm doing let's
say
the the comic book the gods dog project
and um
even this this youtube stuff this like
little youtube celebrity thing you know
this has a cost
it costs something
um
it doesn't it's not free
and the cost it has
is something like becoming a dog at the
edge of the table which
that's that's what this costs so you
could say that
doing this not just the nft project
the gods dog project itself making a
comic book about a story like that
and doing these youtube things and these
youtube videos and
doing interviews and talking about
movies and doing that all of that kind
of stuff
is something like
losing crowns in heaven
uh
and uh
and like i'm not i'm not a i'm not how
can i say this um
i want i want people to understand that
i'm completely aware
of it and i'm and
and i'm not want to excuse any of it but
i'm completely aware
that it's uh
it's walking into the waters and so
the nft project is part of that it is it
is exactly part of that
and it is in a way what we are doing
is we are
diving into the carnival
at
completely like we're not
we're not skimping out we're doing the
carnival
um
and let's just say that
we hope
and i hope that in the end the fruits of
this will be worse
will be worth
it um
but uh
i'm fully aware that
this is like cpr guys
this is like uh you know you you don't
you don't do cpr on a on a healthy
person
because it will kill that person
you do cpr on a dying person as a last
ditch thing
to get it across the waters
and so
so i hope that makes sense
um
and so so
so i'm thinking about it quite a bit and
uh i'm weighing the cost of it
so
hopefully that helps and i hope that
makes sense to you
all right here we go
so
sea street soul
so birds are considered to be the living
relatives of dinosaurs
considering that birds relate to heaven
and more spiritual elevated things and
dinosaurs are extinct monsters on the
edge of our understanding whose remains
are found in the ground as fossil stones
what does this mean symbolically is
there a parallel between angels and
demons of course there's any parallel
between angels and demons
there how many stories
do you know about demons being fallen
angels or that there's a that that which
is below is a fallen version
of that which is above
and so
but i'm not sure i mean
birds are considered to be living
relatives of dinosaurs i mean i don't
know like in this weird like in these
evolutionary things uh the way that
identity they they understand identity
is so strange so convoluted that it's
like uh you know is uh
it's like is the is the michelangelo
considered a relative of you know like
my driveway stones like is that how it
works like how how do they think of
identity
so this is the weird thing about the
idea of relatives it's like
what you know
it's like our dogs relatives of cats i
guess you know they somewhere they are
somewhere down the line everything's a
relative of everything else and so i i
struggle to find a lot of meaning
i struggle to find a lot of meaning in
uh in the way that modern scientific
people
um
understand identity i feel like it's uh
it's it's somehow misunderstood and
arbitrary or at least it or it's
weaponized like like it's weird to say
that dinosaurs are relatives of birds
like okay
you
when do you decide that that's a fact
like why don't you say why don't you say
uh
birds are relatives to amoebas like why
don't you say that why do you say birds
are relatives to dinosaurs anyway sorry
sorry sorry sorry sorry all right no
science bashing it's we don't need more
of that all right
um
all right so brian h says greetings
jonathan i'm fairly new to the symbolic
world and i'm interested in unicorns
well my four-year-old daughter is and as
a parent i would like to have a deeper
understanding of them the bible mentions
them a few times and the atheists use it
to mark the bible as a fairy tale and
most christians say that the unicorn is
actually a mistranslated word for rhino
is it just a translation issue or is
there the symbolic meaning for unicorns
well there's definitely a symbolic
meaning for unicorns and it's also fine
to say that a unicorn is a rhinoceros
that's totally fine because a rhinoceros
is a unicorn i don't know what to tell
you as much as as much as a hippopotamus
is a river horse
a rhinoceros
is a unicorn it's a horse with one horn
it just depends how you categorize
things people
ancient just had different types of
categories i don't know what to tell you
they just didn't have the same kind of
taxonomical categories that we have and
so
so i'm totally fine with um
with uh
unicorns being uh
indian rhinos because
african rhinos have two horns but indian
rhinos have one
so it's totally fine now if you want to
understand uh unicorn you can understand
the notion of so that's why unicorns on
the one hand they represent something
magical because
they represent unity they represent you
know the two becoming one
and um
[Music]
there's actually some interesting some
interesting things about unicorns
there's somebody told me a crazy story
about unicorns which is that they're i
don't know even where they do this but
there's some places where
um
they they when um
goats are very young
what they'll do is for one goat they'll
they'll press the horns together like
physically when like the the skin is
still malleable and everything is kind
of mushy in there they kind of press the
horns together and if you do it in a
certain way or whatever for a certain
amount of time the horns will actually
kind of stick together and then we'll
grow up into one horn and so they'll be
uh like goat unicorns and those goat
unicorns immediately become the alpha
goats
because of their one horn so that's
super interesting right if you think
about a hierarchy at the top of a
hierarchy um so that is that is very
very fascinating um
and so but then there's also a man in
which the idea that unicorn is something
which cannot
um be tamed because it's it's somewhat
unreasonable it doesn't stand on two
doesn't have two so because it's it's
it's almost like if you think of you
could understand a cyclops with one eye
being something like the third eye and
so having like an eye in the middle
which balances the two eyes out but you
could also understand the cyclops as a
maniacal
in terms of single-mindedness and and
something which is impossible to contain
because it's so
kind of focused on one thing
there's actually interesting uh someone
wrote a great article about that for
symbolic world so you can check that out
if you want
but there's definitely something about
what's going on now with unicorns uh
that is very disturbing you know the
whole
the whole uh like
gender unicorn and the idea of like the
relationship between the unicorn the
kind of rainbow unicorn that's what's
interesting about that is it it seems to
have something to do with the idea that
it is an imaginary being and that this
whole kind of gender stuff that we're
going through is
about imagination and it's about
the reality of imagination that you can
imagine what you are and that you can
kind of decide
what is real and so that's what's that's
why people seem to be obsessed with
unicorns right now it seems to be
related to that somehow you know so
yeah that's weird
so kiana a random man says now i want to
see cyclops marketed to five-year-olds
you could probably do it if you did it
properly
all right okay so here we go so now
we're moving to the patreon
site to the patreon side of the q a
so christian swenson asks what is the
symbolism of the butler and the baker in
prison with joseph
good question good question
and so
the so the butler is the one who gives
the wine
to christ
so the butler
is the
left hand of the emperor
and the baker
is the one who gives
the bread
to the to the to the king to the pharaoh
and so he is the right hand
of the pharaoh now if you know your
iconography you probably mostly don't
but if you
look for an icon of holy communion
that is usually represented as a fresco
in the church
you will see christ sometimes cries
double like to christ or sometimes one
where with his right hand he's giving
the bread to saint peter and with his
left hand he's giving the wine to saint
paul
and what happened to saint paul did
saint paul lose his head
did he did saint paul lose his head
sorry to laugh at you say paul that's
horrible but i i'm trying to point to
how powerful the biblical symbolism is
and just how how contained it is and how
traditional symbolism is powerful so in
the story of say of joseph
the baker both of them
uh at the end of the time both of them
are
are let's say elevated by
the the um
elevated by the the the pharaoh and one
is elevated back into his presence and
the other is elevated to lose his head
but i think actually that
i think that it's the opposite
if my memory serves me correctly in the
story is it the baker that loses his
head i think so
but it
whether it's one or the other in a way
it doesn't matter because it has to do
with that it has to do with the
relationship between
the the the right hand and the left hand
the bread and the wine and also kind of
how it
crosses sometimes
um it's very powerful and definitely
worth meditating on more and i should
probably meditate on more because i
don't even remember which one of them
loses their heads but it's definitely
related to saint peter and saint paul to
the bread and the stone to the wine and
and then
saint paul and the sword and losing his
head it's all related it's all like a
big giant puzzle that um
that we should be meditating on that is
for sure
all right so matthew f says i'm
intrigued by your i believe all the gods
exist
take can you help me understand why
scripture sometimes emphasizes idol
worship as merely material example two
kings 19 18 they have cast their gods to
the fire for they were not gods but the
work of men's hands wood and stone
therefore they were destroyed thank you
and so
i mean i think
you know i think that you always have to
understand
you have to see there are two tendencies
in scripture
and this is going to you're going to see
it all the time which is that
on the one hand you'll have a sense that
a good key to that is actually in the
orthodox liturgy so in the orthodox and
it has to do with the um i did a video i
think recently about that about kind of
the difference between apophatic and
cataphatic the relationship between the
two so in the orthodox liturgy right
before we take
communion the priest says
he lifts up the the gift and he says
holy things for the holy
and then the church answers
one is holy
one is god
jesus christ to the glory of god the
father amen
and so what is happening like we're
about to take communion
we're about to to to consume the bread
and the wine and all through the liturgy
we we
we also you know uh praise the saints we
praise all these different
you know these different aspects of of
the body of christ you know we bow
before the priest the priest bowed
before us so what is going on right and
so
you see the same
in in in scripture where for example
there's a there's several places in the
old testament where people bow down
before the altar or people bow down
before
their father bow down before people
they've sinned against all of this is
kind of happening there are other places
for example like when you see the
apostles the the someone bows down
before the apostles and the apostles say
no we are not
like we are men like you
and so it's like what is happening and
this is the problem of this whole
question and so on the one hand you
could say
you could say something like
nothing exists only god exists
right you could say that
and in a manner it would be true
but then you could also say that
all that exists exists through god and
all that exists
is an image of god and therefore god is
hidden in all the things that exist
everything hides god
in it
right and so those two
statements
are so completely opposite but they are
necessary to maintain the balance of
reality which is on the one hand god is
completely above all things and all the
other gods are all false gods they don't
all the other gods don't exist all the
other gods are are just
imagination they're whatever they're all
this stuff
but then there's also a sense in which
all these layers also manifest
our angels they are messengers of the
higher the higher levels down to the
lower levels so when you read scripture
you'll sometimes find certain passages
which emphasize just one side and you'll
find other passages which emphasize the
other side and when you meet someone who
just wants one side
right that's what heresy is
heresy is choosing one side and not in
blinding yourself to the other aspects
and so that's the great thing about our
tradition and the great thing about
christianity and about the bible is that
you always kind of have to take it
in its totality you can't just take a
verse pull it out and say see
see what this verse says this verse says
you know that
that you can't do any works like all the
works you do are dead it's like okay
yeah there's also this other verse but
no no this is the one that's important
so you always have to take things all
together hopefully that helps you
understand why sometimes
the all these these intermediary layers
are seen as dangerous and bad and there
are other times where all these
intermediary layers are seen as
messengers and as angels coming down to
talk to you know to tell the mother of
god that she's going to bear christ that
angels come down to give messages that
they appear as the angel of the lord you
know all of that
yeah you need both
um
all right so doosan
asks what is the symbolism of enoch and
elijah being taken into heaven while
still alive
and not experiencing physical death
please elaborate a bit that's so
extraordinary but i haven't found some
deeper explanation of that
um
okay
there are several things going on
in those in those stories they're all
ultimately related to christ because
christ also ascends into heaven bodily
um
the one thing that it has to do with
for sure it has to do with
a transition of worlds
and um
it's there it's there the pattern is
there i'm telling you the pattern is is
is so
present but
it's
it's hard to code totally understand why
it has to happen that way so there isn't
there isn't just enoch and elijah right
there's
enoch ascends before what
right inaka stands before the flood
elijah ascends
at the fall of the northern kingdom and
so there's
after crossing the jordan so enoch
or before crossing the jordan you could
say crosses once and then before
crossing back then elijah goes up and so
you see enoch going up before the flood
and then you see moses
going up before they enter into the
promised land because although moses
dies
there's a tradition which we find in the
in the scripture in
in the new testament
that says that his body was taken by
saint michael
so moses's body was taken even though he
died
his body was taken
and so you see again when the ethiopian
eunuch is baptized then you see
philip being taken up into heaven it's
very vague about what that all means and
so there seems to be
something about
there seems to be something about
something about the the head of
something or the the highest aspect of
something going into heaven
and that is what causes the transition
you need that to happen for the world to
change for the world to find
a new
name a new a new identity
so you need to have some kind of
ascension
and so what it means bodily
it seems to have something to do with
how in a certain manner the body is is
is contained to a certain extent in
heaven in a certain way
that
the body is contained uh you could say
the pageant
i'm going to say things that i'm going
to regret later that
like saint paul said there are spiritual
bodies that there are more that there
are a capacity for the body to be
contained in its principle maybe let's
say it that way or the possibilities of
the body contained in its principle uh
that is as close as i'm gonna get to
helping you understand that
because because that is some that is
like that is a
understanding that symbolism man
and you know what is related to this and
this is something that metier has been
has has gotten me because
that's also why in revelation and
mathieu really is the one who said
jonathan
your your anti-protestantism is
preventing you from seeing a pattern
which is that that's also why it says in
scripture that
that you know the saints will be taking
taken up into heaven and will meet meet
christ
in the sky
before
the end
and i was like
yeah it's there with enoch and elijah
and moses i'm not saying i believe in
the rapture in in the in a very kind of
in the very crass way that people are
talking about the rapture but for sure
that that pattern
is the same the pattern of the of of the
being taken up into heaven before the
end of the the world is related to enoch
elijah moses
and all these
figures so yeah so i just gave you guys
a nice doozy there huh
that's really from material meant it was
really like he was chiding me he's like
not getting it all right
so wyatt lawrence asked what is the
symbolism of bearing spices
myrrh
so do you
i don't know if murr is mur a spice
uh
isn't myrrh like a like an oil that is
meant to um
that is used for example for embalming
and for all those kinds of things
so um yeah so sorry i don't know i'm not
sure it's a spice
all right
so papercut asked hi jonathan reading
legends of saint nicholas i found the
story of the evil butcher for those who
don't know it goes that three children
were gleaning fields stayed out too late
and getting lost found a butcher shop
the butcher lets them stay the night but
while they're sleeping kills them chops
them up and stores them in a pickling
barrel saint nicholas arrives several
years later realizes what has happened
and resurrects the children
the story has a lot of symbolism of the
fringe remnant nice catch gleaning yes
night
being lost and the butcher but is there
a particular symbolism of the pickling
brine
intuitively it makes me think of bitter
waters yeah dude you got it what is the
symbol of turning a man into a pickle
uh it also has to do with wine it has to
do with uh yeah it has to do with
changing turning fermentation
on itself
uh it has to do with using um
the bitter waters
salt or vinegar or
fermentation
to preserve
rather than to destroy
so it's like one of the hidden aspects
of the lower world which is something
that i've
mentioned a few times i think i've
mentioned a few times which is that this
is why it's difficult sometimes to think
about the symbolism because
the earth let's say the lower part of
the of the pattern
it's both dissolution rotting
breaking down into elements
and preserving
which is why you find ancient things
hidden underground which is why you find
uh
that's why you find treasures
underground you find the stuff you find
precious things underground and so
that's one aspect of the lower
lower part of the world um
and so
that's exactly what saint nicholas does
right saint nicholas
is already related to the the the
solstice is already related to
let's say
giving back seed
giving back
value to things which have been devalued
or have been turned into
that's why he saves the the girls that
are going to be sold into slavery by
giving them a golden ball right by
giving them an identity by giving them a
seed a precious thing he's able to save
them from slavery he's able to save them
from falling into these lower aspects
and in here you basically have
the idea of
you basically have the idea of something
like how
christianity is actually able to
preserve
and resurrect
some aspects of the pagan worlds like
some aspects of the strange
you know in the same way that for
example christianity
is the one who preserved and gave new
life to the to the uh poet to the eddas
that christianity is the one that
preserved and gave new life to the greek
roman myths to
all of these old stories
that is one of the mysteries of
christianity
and so
yeah
it's finding finding uh
yeah
that's that's what it is and so it's a
great story it's a wonderful story
all right so jason lindsey says hey
jonathan in the story of the frog prince
why is the violent action of the
princess throwing him against the wall
the event that finally causes his
transformation into a person
yeah i've been thinking about that i've
been thinking about that um
[Music]
i think i think i think that in the
story what it's supposed to be
i think it has to do with the fact that
the frog has to die
i think it's supposed to die and i think
that's why we see that gesture you don't
totally need it but
for sure and it's one it's for some
reason it's just an aspect of the story
which often gets um ignored when people
retell it
um
but i think that's why that happens i
think the frog is supposed to die and
then in that death
uh you know the prince is born out of
that death and so you can imagine like
the boy has to die for the man to live
that's what an initiation is
that's what baptism is that's what you
know rights of passage are where some
aspect of you has to die in order for
the new one to be
to be born
so i think that's what's going on there
all right so manuel montiel says
when i've discussed religious notions of
demons and principalities with
materialists they always refer back to
some sort of physical phenomena to
explain it and state that the religious
notions were just a way of explaining
something the ancients didn't have the
knowledge or right language
e.g and addiction to porn more precisely
be explained by hormone psychology
instead of possession basically a game
of linguistics to them
where they have the proper accurate
language i know they aren't wrong in
describing the physical phenomena but
it's as if it is completely it as if it
completely ends there for them as if i'm
talking to a wall since it's just word
games for them what do you think the
appropriate response would be then to
this claim and so
uh look man
i want to be honest with you
you do what you can and then at some
point you stop throwing pearls to swine
like this is an exact example of
throwing pearls to swine because you are
trying to show them
the identity of something and the
pattern of something and they are blind
to it they cannot see
that there's an overarching pattern
and so
i would say just just just do what you
can and then don't take it personal if
they they don't understand it
because some people are just blind like
if you watch some of the conversations
i've had on my channel
it is so frustrating for people that
have the insight
and can see
to watch someone not only dismiss what
you're saying but do it arrogantly as if
they as if you're just a superstitious
idiot you know um and i would say like
the best thing you can do is to actually
find joy
in that you know i actually find joy in
it now because you know i get annoyed
but i usually just
have a secret joy which is that look man
you think i mean you think that i'm an
idiot like you you actually think that
i'm a superstitious idiot and you're
like
there's something about that which
brings me pleasure i don't know what to
say
so i wish i could help you man
i wish i could help you
um
all right so ron wood what is the
symbolism of honorable ritualistic
suicide especially harakiri her kiri
plunging weapon into one's belly cutting
across shape
i was able to participate in the kendo
club in japan at the end of the practice
we would all sit and unformally gather
ourselves at the leader's instruction
with hands
clasped in a circle over the belly
similar to how the sign of the cross of
the orthodox church is said to land on
the belly rather than the heart to
signify conquering the passions
is this perhaps partly where a cross is
cut into the belly during uh seppuku
i don't know i really i wish i knew i
don't know enough about
japanese symbolism
to uh to uh to understand that it
probably has something to do with that
it probably has something to do with
if you're doing if you're really doing
like a cross gesture that it's really
about like an x right like you know how
you cross out something to say that it
stops existing
that's probably what it is it's like
you know it's a it's a
cross it's like let's say the two
intersecting aspects you know of
identity and potential but now it's it's
basically cutting it open so that you
cease existing
that seems to be the best i could do
with that but i would i would have to
know more about that symbolism
all right so reuben corp says hey
jonathan as your symbolic world have you
been much influenced by the fourth
senses of scripture
historical allegorical moral and
anagogical develop from origins writing
for use in exodus in the west if so if
not how would you see are your own
approach as interacting or responding to
this kind of exegesis and so
um
i i think that that's great i think that
that type of interpretation is is
perfect
but
um
i would say that
i would say that for example if origin
was able to
describe the four senses and others in
his wake it's because they perceived a
common pattern across the four senses
and so
i think one of the things that we are
free to do which was maybe more
difficult for the ancients to do because
they were so imbibed in it so in a
certain manner the reason the fact that
we are
more alienated from this worldview means
that we are also able to
possibly be more fractal about these
meanings and realize that the sense
of scripture these four levels contain
indefinite levels in between them
and that
and that it really is a pattern of
reality
um and i think that if i it's like i i
might be arrogant but i think that if i
was sitting with origen and origen had
the insight of the last
you know 2000 years and especially
modernism i think that he would have
absolutely no problem with that that he
would find it completely
in tune with what he's saying
so that's what i think
hey so jacob is in the house all right
jacob
thanks for showing up that's awesome and
seeing you here for a little while
so arthur holmes brown
says do we eat our pets
i rece i recently listened to yourself
and went to expanding the concept of
eating yeah as the life of our pet cat
or dog is largely lived and given to
bring us comfort and joy is that a form
of gathering into ourselves i eating
i may have duplicated this question in
the youtube chat maybe um all right so
no you're you're you have a good insight
about it and so
it's it's uh
how can i say this it's harder
for people to understand the way you're
describing it but it's right
is that you have to understand your pets
as extensions of of you basically in a
similar manner as your children are
but sometimes what happens with pets
which is interesting you know
if you want to know a lot about someone
look at how he treats his pets
because the manner in which
the
the relationship that you have with your
kids or your family is mediated by
by a lot of psychology and a lot of
other stuff competition all of these
things there's a lot of stuff which when
you see a master and his pet is not
there it's a more direct relationship
it's more of a mind to body relationship
and um
and so you and so you can get a lot
about people if you watch their pets and
how they treat them and how their pets
um
interact with them
and there's also a way in which you can
understand how
the modern world will tend towards the
opposite we'll tend
towards people
treating their pets as their gods like
treating their pets as kings that they
serve
um and that is just an inevitable side
effect of
of the kind of upside-down world that we
uh that we live in you know
i'm sure a lot of people are laughing
hearing that right now
because they know people that do that
all right so garth natwick nate wick
natwik says hello jonathan recently i
decided to invest myself into the craft
of stained glass so i might as well ask
the common cliche question on this
channel what is the symbol of stained
glass windows
um
i mean sunglass windows are wonderful i
love them they're really more western
for sure in terms of their
application um and i mean it's great to
have you have light coming through
images how how better could you get you
know so i think that that's what it was
i think it was the idea of being able to
see
these patterns these stories these
images of people that we
that we revere you know basically
shining you know to us in light
and so i think that that's the uh
so there's actually probably a
relationship between the kind of
automatic veneration people get from
being on screens i've mentioned this
before which is i think one of the
things that make us so
um
so strange our strange interaction with
people on screens is that you're looking
at someone that's just light you're
basically looking at someone that's
shining towards you um and so i think
that that that's probably part of the
star phenomena
is uh is related to that as well
so
so that's what it is and they're
wonderful yeah definitely
um so dorothea says are christmas and
hanukkah symbolically
somehow related or is it a coincidence
that they occur around the same time
no they're definitely related and not
just christmas but theophany or epiphany
is
is definitely related and so epiphany or
theophany is the older of the feast
it was celebrated before christmas in
the in the for by the early christians
and it if you look at the symbolism of
epiphany or theophany it is the
symbolism of light it is all about light
it's about it's all about the revelation
of the logos which is why at epiphany
you have
people might find it confusing because
it's not just a celebration
of of an event for example we it had it
became that with time where in the
orthodox church we celebrate the baptism
and in the west people celebrate the the
kings who reckon who come to recognize
christ but we if we look at the
different symbolism it's all about the
revelation of the logos and so you see
the uh at
theophany there are allusions to the
wedding of kana their allusions to the
baptism allusions to the birth and then
allusions to the three kings that is the
the moments in which the light shines
forth in the darkness or out of the
darkness so it has to do with
preservation of light in the time of the
solstice as well like this light that is
almost running out and so you have this
one light which survives into the new
world and then shines brightly to kind
of illuminate the new the new cycle or
the new world and so the so it's a very
much a similar symbolism between
christmas and hanukkah and i think that
i think that probably to a certain
extent that consciously so that it just
happened that way because the jews that
that transferred the celebration of
hanukkah into epiphany we're very much
aware of all the symbolism that was
related to this little light that was
preserved and
shown in the darkness yeah
um all right
so jacob says what do what did i do now
do you guys so jacob and bradley are
fighting in the chat you know you need
you the family keep your family problems
outside of the chat guys we don't
we don't watch our dirty clothes in
public okay
all right so christian clais says hello
brother maximus
what is the symbol symbolism of the
copia meme
if you don't know what it is can you
elaborate on why most icons of the
crucifixion depict jesus without the
crown of thorns
does it have something to do with him
already being depicted with a halo
thanks merry christmas so i don't know
what the copia mean meme is copium
you guys keep just uh just uh
you guys just keep exposing my
uh my boomer-ness
um
so i guess it has something to do with
the idea of
like coping with some kind of i don't
know guys i wish i knew
i would have to check on it but i can
answer to you why christ does not
represent with the crown of thorns on
the cross is because christ
didn't have a crown of thorns on the
cross you know the cross happens during
the moment of the eche homo moment when
when um
when uh pontius pilate presents christ
to the crowd and he has a crown of
thorns and he's wearing the the you know
the the purple he has a reed in his hand
as a mockery of a king
and so that's why most of the time it's
not represented on its head on the cross
i actually don't have a problem with
representing the the crown of thorns on
the cross um occasionally
because you know for the same reason
that
icons condense events right they they
just condense events into one and so i
think that it could be you it could be
useful or it could be possible to do
that but it would
it would have to be an exception because
it's really not traditional to do that
um all right so
mid mid
mid muhammad ali says bonsoir jonathan
the bible contains many references to
slavery
which was the commonest practice in
antiquity biblical texts outlined
sources and legal status of slaves
economic roles
of slavery types of slavery and debt
slavery which thoroughly explains the
institution of slavery in israel in
antiquity how do you reconcile these
acts in today's world especially
in these verses in the bible
and he named some verses to name a few
merci um
so all right
i guess that was gonna that was bound to
happen one day
and so
i think we need to understand that
in the bible what's important
is the manner in which we treat
those
that are
around us
and you can say that
the type of social hierarchy
this type of social hierarchy is in some
manner it is
let's say inevitable
and so even whether you understand a
slave as the actual property of someone
whether you understand a slave as a type
of servitude
which you are required to
offer to someone for whatever reason
whether you sell yourself to that person
in a in a
because of debt
um whether you are taken as a prisoner
during war
you owe you owe servitude to the people
that took you all of these types of
things
what's important in the way that
scripture talks about these
relationships is rather
how to treat those that are below you
that is the emphasis that is put in
scripture so the idea is not whether or
not slaves should exist or not
it seems to me that in this to a certain
extent in scripture there is a sense
that
it understands that these types of
hierarchies are going to happen one way
or the other so there's an emphasis on
the idea of rather how to treat the
people that are below you and how to
even though they are socially below you
that they
that they are let's say
socially owe you money or socially owe
you servitude or you this or owe you
that that they are ultimately your
brother and sister
be in christ if especially if they are
christian they are
you know they are made in the image of
god you know and so
all of this is is kind of it's what is
most important in scripture because
like i don't want to excuse uh slavery
there's no there's no point in that but
let's say without without something like
slavery
it's a
in a traditional world
you need
we have what we have today we have
massive huge
state-funded welfare state
and that is
a great way to avoid slavery because
one of the problems of just thinking
that slavery is bad
always bad in itself is that
if you have someone let's say imagine
this like imagine you take prisoners of
war
from from another country and now you
you take them you kill you know you
destroy their land you destroy
everything about them you bring them you
just take them
and then
then you just set them free free to do
what what are they going to do they're
going to die in the wilderness or not
don't have any food they won't have any
they won't have anything
and so
there is a double bind in the in the
idea of slavery especially like
a proper relationship which is that if i
if someone owes me servitude
i owe them
to i owe them to take care of them
especially in a world that believes in
god especially in a world that believes
in a transcendent good um
um and so this is the issue this is the
this is what's most important in the way
that christians talk about this question
in in the ancient world now
i celebrate as much as the next person
that ultimately christianity ultimately
led to a world where slavery doesn't
exist anymore because then the reality
of
the image of god in the other becomes
far more
bright and far more apparent and far
more real in our experience
but i think that that's the best way to
understand why it is that
it continues to kind of exist in the in
the ancient world
and to be honest it also exists
today it's like
um
how can i say this like right now
i am not allowed to leave my country
right now
i am not allowed to take a plane right
now i am not allowed to go into a
restaurant
so people who think that they're not a
slave of something they are deluding
themselves
just because you have the favor of your
master
doesn't mean you're not also a slave
and so
um
[Music]
all right let's move on from this
all right here we go roman glass hey
jonathan
i keep coming across a phrase both in
fictional literature and secular
spirituality the journey is more
important than the destination
like you're listening to my injury with
sticks weren't you my question is what
are your thoughts on this is this at
odds with the christian story where the
eschaton is the whole point of the story
thank you merry christmas and happy new
year
um
so
how can i say this
this destination
is the reason
for your journey
and the journey
provides the transformation
necessary
to acquire the destination
okay
i think that that's the best way to
understand it
and
there's also
it's like if you take if you take that
phrase you know and you just
try to apply it fractally okay like
seriously try to apply it for actually
cooking is more important
than eating your meal
um
let's keep going you know it's like
flirting
is more important
than having a date
and dating
is more important
than what it's what it leads to
it's like just to try to apply that
sentence fractally
um
and you'll notice just how just silly it
is it's silly
uh and so
so the best way to understand it let's
see from an orthodox perspective is that
the the end goal or the eschaton is not
a static thing and also the the end goal
is not static right in saint gregory of
nissa we saint gregory nisa talks about
the movement from glory to glory so you
have to understand it as this moving up
and these steps
giving
opening up towards more and always
opening up towards higher and higher and
more and more and so it's not as if you
reach the destination and then you're
dead it's that
reaching these lower accomplishments and
low higher
states will open up even higher and more
lofty uh experiences and states for you
so i think that that's a more proper way
of understanding it because the other
one sounds nice but it's actually
people who haven't thought it through in
my opinion
all right so maximus maggiar says what
are some good sources of orthodox lives
of saint
the lives of the saints and the
horologion seem very sterilized and seem
to exclude the parts of the stories that
you would focus on the horologion also
says that iconographers who depicts on
christopher dog-headed are ignorant
um
yeah
so i would say you know what a good
place for the story of sciences right
now to be honest is wikipedia i mean
wikipedia is actually right now is uh is
a great source if you're if you can read
it carefully and i'll be attentive to
the places where they are ideological
then it tends to accumulate a lot of the
stuff that the modern reformers of
religion tried to get rid of and so you
can actually find some pretty
interesting things
on um
on wikipedia so
so samuel ramilera in the chat says our
restrictions on canada is still that
harsh they are becoming harsher
and they are not looking like they will
let up
so
yeah
all right so here we go so romer
says hi jonathan
i've been intrigued by the apparently
far-fetched idea that i figured like
saint christopher so easily imagined as
simply a brute could perhaps be seen as
a brutish sort of translator
something like a giant foreign
two-headed
scribe carrying words little logie from
one language to the other undertaking
even greater and more difficult tasks
serving even more powerful voices until
quite unexpectedly he finds himself
carrying the divine logos himself
between two worlds what do you think
could the symbolism of translations be
meaningfully transferred to the stories
of saint christopher
and other bar barbarians yes who strove
to transport the word of god across the
world thank you and apologies for the
long question um
no i understand you're i understand your
your idea and
i think that i mean
yeah sure there's definitely a
relationship between saying christopher
the translator and the translation
and the idea of reaching the the strange
you know there's a relation there's a
relationship of taming too
there are some versions of the story of
saint christopher where when he gets to
the other side then he loses his
ugliness right he becomes a
normal man there are other versions of
dog-headed saints converting which have
that trope for example
in the legend of saint andrew
um the the kind of
all these stories about saint andrew you
know going around the world and uh
evangelizing he meets this brute called
abominable and it's a big giant
dog-headed sinus you know cannibal uh
monster
and when he converts he he becomes a
human and then he changes his name from
abominable to christian so it's like a
beautiful fairy tale you know
hagiography
so i know i like your idea i like your
idea of uh of the idea of um
of this kind of monster that that
crosses over
like translation
all right so drew mcmahon asked hi
jonathan do you have seen an mma in
general seem to be taking over the
sports world or maybe it's just my
bubble how do you interpret the rise of
comet sports and its crossover into
mainstream lots of participation at
local levels
among everyday folks as well thank you
i mean it's not surprising because
because fighting is basically the
boiling down all sports to one thing
basically two guys fighting and then one
being better than the other
so it's not surprising that that would
happen
you know
i also think that as christianity
wanes let's say i think that that it's
inevitable that the kind of gladiatorial
combat would would return
so you know
all right connor in your conversation
with matt fred you use the example of a
carbing millions of things and one thing
at the same time
in the ontological hierarchy how does an
example like this
necessitate a supreme being at the
highest level i'm struggling to see how
you make the jump from car to god
that has something to do with god
revealing himself as being three persons
in one essence yes it does exactly
unity and multiplicity and this quality
of many beings being one is an attribute
that all beings share
and so
uh
yes but there's it's more than that it's
like uh
if you ride the ontological hierarchy if
you write it up
just conceptually if you just do it
conceptually you run into a problem at
some point because
you come to the one
you come to the one which is behind all
the multiple
right
and so
that's why you have that move in
something like neoplatonism you have
that move in
in
things like hinduism
which is that as you if you ride the the
category structure the ontological
hierarchy you get to something like
being
then you get to something like
uh being a non-being because for being
to multiply there has to be something
like non-being
or else you can't you can't escape the
monad if you don't have some notion of
non-being so like being a non-being
as the ultimate one let's say
so it's it's really is once you
understand that that's how the world
works then you it just quickly becomes
inevitable but the mystery that
christianity reveals i think is that
the the multiplicity the three
is not lower
from the one which is a total mystery
without but also solves a lot of
problems it all solves a lot of problems
in terms of
of the idea that the world is uh fallen
and the world is like an illusion or
maya or that the world is uh corrupt in
itself you know which you see in a lot
of uh kind of gnostic thinking
and in some strands of of hinduism and
buddhism
um that we have to escape the world
right we always have to escape because
we have to escape into the monad we have
to dissolve back
into the one you know if you read some
mystics like some hindu mystics for
example they have this this sense in
which you know you have to dissolve back
into brahma because everything is an
illusion all multiplicity is an illusion
this is something that the trinity
is an attempt to solve which is that
in
the in the infinite unity and
multiplicity are
are fully there
and therefore
the multiplicity of the world
is a bond of love rather than
a scandal and a kind of uh
and just a fall
can be a bond of love at least even
though we do see a fallen aspect of it
you know
um
so janet horseman asks
am i right to understand a garment of
skin as something neutral if so is our
current movement towards transhumanism
just another garment of skin my 20 year
old can't wait to live in a world like
ready player one and just sees it as an
inevitable step toward forwarding
technology but i find this idea
terrifying is this overacting
and so
the garments of skin
are the best way to understand is that
the garments of skin are not neutral
yeah they're neutral but neutral in the
sense that they are
positive and negative at the same time
right that
they
the more you increase the garments of
skin the more in you're in more and more
danger of forgetting
the essence of forgetting the life of
forgetting the meaning
because you you keep adding these layers
um and you're always in danger of
forgetting
but
you're also increasing your power all
the time
um
and so and one of the problems with the
garments of skin is that they tend to
seduce us into thinking that they're the
thing
so for example like
their 20 year old like you said they
can't wait to live in a world like ready
player one
it's like already that's a serious
problem because
i mean this is gonna sound corny but
it's like he's not asking himself
how could i continue to love my neighbor
in a world like ready player one
he's saying
he's excited about the the world itself
he's excited about the technology in the
garment he's not asking himself how it
can supplement
the true and the beautiful and the and
the you know and the real
sort of that makes sense
um
so yeah that's up that's it
all right so charles harold says
what is giving you hope about the
current situation of continuing
lockdowns in government overreach
man what's giving me hope
and i'll be totally honest with you
right now i do not have much hope
and uh it's just a moment it'll pass but
it's just because
the news about how things are going to
be dealt with let's say
around me
was given to me just a few days ago
and um
and i haven't completely uh
haven't completely digested it let's say
and i'm struggling to uh
to deal with it and so
let me tell you what my only hope is in
the current situation
my only
hope is that adversity breeds strength
and adversity breeds dedication and so
what i hope for myself
is that losing
this that
losing how easy it is to go to church
and to worship and to be in communion
will make me value it more and make me
strive for it more
so that's my hope
all right patrick varchola
asks
hi jonathan my question is about ways in
which principalities manifest in our
physical world what differences are
there between people embodying
principality willing or unwillingly e.g
king embodying angel or the kingdom or
demon of lust possessing a person
and principalities taking particular
physical or rather visible form ig
archangel gabriel visiting mary and how
incarnation of christ fits in all of
this thank you
um
i don't know i don't know why that's so
complicated for you
and so
so think about it this way think about
it like um
everything that exists
is both an agent and a body
it's about someone something that is
acting on the world
and something which is being acted upon
and is a body
for other things
right and so that's true of everything
in the world
uh
and especially intelligent obviously
especially intelligent agents
so you
are
the body
of your
family a part of the body of your family
you are
a body for your state
your body for your
facebook group or your body for whatever
it is that you engage in that has a
higher identity than you
your body for certain causes your by
your body for certain political
ideologies
you're a body for
you know your city's recycling program
like whatever it is that you that you
act
in and you can be a body for that now
you're also
a principal
for sure your principle to a certain
extent for things that are
under your power you could say
um
and so
that's the way it works and so you know
the difference between let's say
so there are more direct and indirect
ways to act or to manifest
so sometimes
things
let's say
let's say let's think about it this way
let me let me let me think about this
let me help you think about it this way
so
let's say i'm the father of my family
and so in my house
there
my my house
mostly my wife and i let's say my wife
and i our house functions as an
extension of our relationship and
therefore there are certain implicit
rules and in certain implicit ways of
being
that have to be maintained in the house
for that to continue to be true so my
kids
when at this point now without me saying
they know how to behave they know what
is acceptable what is not acceptable
they know how to engage with each other
they know
what their responsibilities are
and then once in a while
let's say
it's time to do the dishes and my child
doesn't do the dishes
and so i have to go knock on their door
and say come do the dishes
and so one is a more direct
implication of the of the principle
where there's a direct communication
which comes down and then informs you of
what you need to do
and and the other one isn't more
indirect your will kind of imbibes the
the body of the thing that you're that
you're the head of and then that just
kind of naturally
exists
um so you know
yeah i hope that helps
all right kevin patterson asked how does
the structure of the trinity relate to
unity and multiplicity we experience in
communion
as in
god is of one substance with three
hypotheses there's at once a unity and a
multiplicity
is it the same dynamic between god and
his church and so
i i i'm afraid i'm going to skip that
question kevin it's not because i don't
want it's just because
i really i want to be careful with
trinitarian theology and leave it to the
experts on trinitarian theology
but for sure there's a relationship
between you there's a relationship of
unity and multiplicity in
in the church
um
you know and christ says be one as my
father
and i are one you know so there's a
relationship there for sure
so any crawford ads did you watch a new
spider-man no way at home what did you
think more and more
we have hero stories with no real
villain what do you think of this trend
and so i know i have not seen it and so
i cannot go to the theater folks you
know that right so i will see it when i
can see it and then that'll be it but no
i have not seen it
all right so nom grenade says my
question is about the orthodox
prohibition on depicting christ as
anything other than himself and icons
if the symbol is symbols our way to
point to a high truth of something why
not admit other representations of him
so long as they point towards divine
glory like christ as the lamb for
example thank you and i hope and pray
that you have a blessed christmas
um
yeah that's a tricky one because because
i i sympathize with the western position
on this
for sure
um but for sure the orthodox church
we're not allowed to represent christ as
a lamb and we don't you know i don't i
don't think i've ever have
and it has to do with how
the old images of that point to christ
or something like shadows
and that we should represent christ
directly now that we have the
incarnation
and so
i get it you know and it's fine i won't
go against the tradition
but i think there's something missing i
think there's there's missing the sense
in which christ also contains in himself
all these
shadows you could say are all these
pointing
and so the point the different parts of
the old testament that are pointing to
him are also like his body you could say
and they are they're the reason or the
the manner in which we're able to
recognize the one christ in the
incarnation
so if you just say well we don't need
those anymore because we've got the
thing
uh i just find that a dubious
explanation and so sorry to go against
the i know i'm not going to go against
you know the fathers of the council but
i just don't i don't totally agree
uh with that i would have liked
something something like
we should represent christ as himself
and then marginally represent him
in his um
in his shadow versions let's say
uh but that let's say in something like
in the apps or you know in the the the
holy of holies or certain places in the
church we should only represent christ
as himself but let's say
in the name and the stories we could
represent him more symbolically
so yeah you know
so joe kelly o'neil says what can you
tell us about the understanding of
symbolism of specific colors meaning
of rudolph's red nose and so i have a by
the way i have a video about rudolph the
red nose reindeer you should check it
out if you want to it's actually one of
my less
my less watch videos for some strange
reason but i think it was a good video i
thought i i really captured the
symbolism of rudolph
and so i mean the symbolism of colors is
really tricky folks i really struggle
with
a lot of it you know i tend
i i tend to see symbolism as patterns
and so i struggle sometimes when people
tell me like a color means this
so for example like if i see blue
opposed to red that did that makes sense
to me you know cool hot there's a
there's like a
light
dark you know and
there's a sense in which that makes a
lot of sense and so and it seems to
intuitively work with like right hand
left hand you know like let's say
green below you know and white above or
glee green and gold
i think that
when you have them in the pattern i i
tend to kind of understand them a little
more but i struggle when people tell me
like white you know yellow means this
and i'm like really yellow means that
it's
i don't know man it's like when i eat a
lemon i don't have that experience of
meaning like i don't have that the same
experience of meaning
um but for example like red is
definitely something
that excites us like in our perception
of it so it's exciting in a positive and
negative way and it's poison
it's uh
it's also flush like if you know when
you're you're you're
when you're embarrassed or when you're
excited your your cheeks become red and
so i think that these are signs that um
that have to do with red with passion
with all that you know and so i think
some of it is right but you know
yeah
so nate barker asked hey jonathan thanks
for all you do what is the symbolism or
significance of the number three in that
god is described as a trinity
you talk about the pentagram i heard you
say that four is a certain stability in
two opposing pairs
so what's significant about three in
this respect why three and one instead
of say four and one earth five and one
and so
three has there's several aspects of
symbolism of three one is that three is
it's a dynamic number
you know because there's no opposites
there because when you have two you have
two things looking at each other and
they they tend to manifest themselves as
opposites if you have four you have a
similar problem or it's not a problem a
similar reality but three
they things
the aspects of three tend to manifest
either as dynamic that is each
corner like a like each aspect
relating to the other or as a triangle
which is that there's one and then the
two
so there's there's the the opposites
which are resolved into unity
and so that's usually the two aspects of
the symbolism of three and you see it
you see both of those aspects of the
symbolism of three sometimes
um represented in the trinity
as well or represented as images of the
trinity
so garrett whitner asked hillary
jonathan i've heard you speak on the
meaning of some of the cardinal
directions north associated with
something like evil south with one's
ancestors but only in passing
i was hoping you could explain this a
bit especially address the meaning of
the west
and so
the the meaning of the four directions
is super important
it's very very important and it's very
complex and it's very multiple
there's one aspect of the four
directions which is directly related to
the sun and the sun
the way the sun rises in the east and
sets in the west and then moves to the
south does it move into the north
and so the north
tends to be uh related to darkness
and then the south as let's say the
as a heat or the place where let's say
the
as heat or light
uh but not in the same way as the east
for example and so let's say the
the bastion of light you could say or
the the cradle of light you could say is
the south
um
and the cradle is a good image let's say
that in that sense and so in the east
then you really have the origin and the
end so the east is the origin of light
and the west is the end of life
um
and so if you understand it related to
the temple for example it's it's really
important where the west is where the
tabernacle the the ark of the covenant
is
and so you know the light you could say
the glory of god rises up in the east
and then lands in the west
you know like it says like a christ is
like a lightning bolt the son of man is
like a
lightning which moves from the the east
to the west
and so it has to do the the origin in
the end
but it gets very complicated very fast
because
depending on
which side which you what direction you
emphasize and so ancient cultures tend
to emphasize east so tended to point to
to uh direct their prayers east or
direct themselves eastward and so then
the north would become the left hand and
the south would become the right hand so
then the north would be related to the
left hand the sense of darkness
and in the sense of crooked in the sense
of all that and then the right would be
related to light to a substitute for the
center all of that stuff
um and then behind you is the west
and so it's related to death it's
related to
that which is behind you i don't want to
tell you right you eat this way
and the residue is that way you know
i could keep talking about this for like
an entire hour i mean obviously i should
make a video about it because there's so
much to be said about the four
directions
um yeah
all right so luca iridze
says whose prayer does god hear when two
people pray for opposite things
um
i would say he listens to both sides
i don't know what to tell you
all right and i mean this what a strange
question like which side does he which
let me let me mess you up if you want
whose prayer does god hear when two
people pray for the opposite things
he listens to the one which the opposite
things happen does that is that okay is
that does that help you like if two
teams are praying to win which prayer
did god listen to the when did the
prayer that the team won
but there's a man in which this is so
pathetic like it's uh
how could not pathetic sorry sorry sorry
sorry like
this is not what religion is about
religion isn't about praying to god to
get things
and i'm not saying it's not a little
part of religion it's it exists in
religion but it's definitely not very
high on the scale of what religion is
about religion is about transformative
participation
and moving up the the the hierarchy
of being into god that's what religion
is about
now
yeah some people ask for cards and some
people ask for stuff and it's like
who cares about that stuff i don't know
what to tell you man
sorry sorry all right i need to stop
stop all right
all right arizona man
ask to what degree do you believe the
recent popularity in nfts and
specifically the community community
element are serving as an updated
placeholder for our inherent need to
participate
was this a technological solution as a
rubber band effect juxtaposing the
covered lockdown from 1 to 10 how hard
should we ate into nft projects that are
christian centered um
and so
i think i really think that most and the
nft stuff is just uh it's a lot it's a
fluffy fluff which is okay because
fluffy fluff fluff
it's not that that doesn't exist it
exists but that's what it is it's fluff
it's a fluff
let's say it's a
it's like a it's a bubble right bubbles
get really big but also bubbles are very
fragile and so that's what nfts seem to
be
uh a lot of the crypto stuff is that in
general it's like it's a bubble and so
it grows and it gets big but it also is
fragile and so i would say
don't put a lot of your soul into nfts
like don't put a lot of your like a lot
of your
let's say central attention into stuff
like that or crypto either like this is
not what our lives are about but there's
nothing wrong with nfts like we did it
you know it was a way to like you said
to to find ways to be able to
participate to a certain extent and to
kind of increase the
the the reach or the glory of the
project of the gods dog project we were
doing it but for me i saw it as a
utilitarian thing like i i saw it
as
adding to the god's dog project and not
as something
in itself
so
so i would say
uh be careful so but nfts are just
contracts so there's a way in which it
could be used in really interesting ways
so i'm still thinking about it like i'm
sure i'm gonna do more and find some
interesting ways to um to make it to
make it to participate in it but i i
definitely
i wouldn't i would need to it would need
to be make sense to me and we need to be
interesting
um
everybody's going crazy with the fluffy
fluff
fluff
[Laughter]
yeah well you know i don't know what to
tell you that's what it is um
you know
so uh so so uh so yeah
um but i really like i enjoyed the doing
the nft thing with you guys for the for
god's dog i really learned quite a few
things and
it was interesting
to notice because we tried to do it in a
way that
was related to kind of narrative secrets
and codes and stuff like that
so to me it was worth doing and i
thought it was um
like it was valuable and so we'll see
what happens i don't know what's going
to happen with that
i definitely told people not to sell
your shirt for for this stuff because
you know it's who knows what's going to
happen
all right
all right so nikola alexik alexis asks
orthodox church as far as i know
prohibits marriage within seven degrees
of kinship in the old testament we find
abraham and sarah married even though
they are closest of kin i'm not sure
what to make of this could you please
help
and so i mean it has to do with
christianity being expansive
you know and and the idea is to spread
the love right so that the christianity
grows
um
um i think that that's what it is but
it's rarely applied let's be honest
because it was crazy like it's not just
seven degrees of kinship it was like
seven degrees of kinship plus seven
degrees of kinship to your godparents
so it was like seven degrees of kinship
to your own relatives and then seven
degrees of kinship to your godparents
so imagine like in a small village it's
like you don't have a lot of
so it it was rarely really applied
um
but you could see that as an ideal as an
ideal for christianity to expand
expand through love instead of expanding
through uh through war let's say
all right so ferret
uh hi jonathan what is the symbolism of
sobriety
can it be a form of excess in some cases
yes if yes how do we wreck how to
recognize when it is
um i mean the thing sobriety is is
easily becomes an idol and i think that
that's when it becomes dangerous you
know you say maximus really talks about
the idea of
the sins of the right hand and sobriety
is it could be a sin of the right hand
where you
you if you attain a certain sobriety
then you have a false confidence in
yourself and you think that you've got
it and you think that you're in charge
and your control and uh
that usually leads to pride and it
usually leads to
a massive fall off
and that's why i say maximum says that
you know once once you let the sins of
the right hand enter
then it opens the door for the sins of
the left hand and so all your sobriety
collapses into
different excesses
and you might even be blind to you
sometimes
all right
so matthew says i have a question about
the resurrection and monstrosity a
monster is that which can't be named a
hybrid of two things or more things the
resurrections can be fully put into
words and it appears like a hybrid
between the human and the angelic
example the resurrected christ eats fish
and he can walk through walls the
problem is besides the fact that
kong's resurrection and monstrosity
seems to be blasphemous it also seems
incorrect the resurrection is at the
center not on the borders where the
monsters are my question then is what am
i misunderstanding about the monsters
and or the resurrection
so
you could say that
the resurrection is is
involves the totality of the beings and
so
the resurrection
because there's something like the the
resurrection contains
the
monsters
or the the margins the resurrection
contains the margins within itself in
their proper place you know and so the
gargoyles are on the outside of the
church
that's an image of the kingdom of god
right an image of the of and so
i don't can't totally tell you like what
that means like in
particular but
it has to do with something like the
wounds of christ remaining on the
resurrected body of christ you know like
a mark of death
which is part of the resurrection you
know
and so a breakdown which is part of the
resurrection how about that
that the the part where christ's body
broke down
where the identity of his body broke
down which was it was pierced
becomes
part of its glory
so yeah
so gregory
vunis asks here is mine do you have any
advice for a new fantasy author
um
i don't know
maybe take uh take our class like we're
gonna set up if that happens i hope it
happens uh with um
with nicholas kotar and paul kingsnorth
and a lot of cool people in theory we're
putting together a
writing seminar
that will be focused mostly on fiction
and uh so these two are great you know
paul king was a great writer and uh
and uh you know um nicholas kotar are
just a wonderful storyteller
and my uh my part is going to be talking
about kind of symbolic world and how to
world build in a way that's coherent so
maybe that could be a way and something
to do but i don't know when it's going
to going to come up uh yet so
um oh sorry the question continues he
says i've started writing a fantasy
series that uses a lot of words
electrician thinking and the way it is
structured of course this will probably
not be obvious that's what actually
tries to see it so yeah that's great i
mean that's awesome i think that's the
future
and i think yeah i think it's the future
that's what we tried to do
so christopher mihaly asked in your
interview with on broadcast you both
said that you wouldn't use owls in your
artwork due to their symbolism what is
that symbolism so i think the reason why
we said that
i don't remember saying that but i guess
i know why is that what i meant is that
for example like although i don't think
pentagrams are evil in themselves
i wouldn't
overtly use pentagrams
in my art just because of the cultural
associations with them and that there's
no need to be scandalous just to be
scandalous and so if people identify a
pentagram with things that are occult or
satanic or whatever or witchcraft then
it's like i wouldn't use it because i
don't why would i scandalize my brother
like why would i
do things in a way that will overtly uh
lead them into to chaos so i think
that's the thing is that the owl now has
become an image of
all these things in terms of moloch and
in terms of like in kind of popular
thinking
um
the idea of of this ancient god and so
because of that then i probably would
use an owl just because it would confuse
people and
you know why would i do that so you know
that's that and so
look at us
it's 10 minutes before the end of the
hour so
pretty awesome not bad
so let's see guys chat
i'm giving you 10 minutes you can ask
questions in the chat
what you got
so it says nicholas kotar was on the
first things foundation youtube channel
cool
and he's written me some messages i've
been so out of it for the holidays i
don't think i've answered any emails any
messages or like very very few and i
know he wrote me about something so
nicholas sorry if you see this i need to
look at your messages
and uh and answer
so matthew
mull brandon says what is the symbolism
of red light districts do you think they
are a valid and or useful way to deal
with inevitable transgressions uh
gambling
i don't know i think they're inevitable
i don't think they're valid like that's
a weird thing to say about that but i
think they're inevitable
um
and so i think that often what which
cultures will do will be tried to manage
that darker aspect of their society in a
way that
understanding that they can't totally
get rid of it
they will try to isolate it
so i think that that's usually what what
happens and that usually makes sense but
it's a dangerous game to play too
because if you iso isolated then you
give it being
and then that being tends to grow
you know and so let's say you disperse
say you have prostitutes all over like a
little few prostitutes all over the
place you know it's annoying because
then you have prostitutes all over the
place and they're they're they're there
um
and so and so
so but it but then they also don't have
a
nation right they don't have a land
and so but if you create a red light
district and you're like okay all
prostitutes and all that stuff go there
then what happens is that that will
exist as a being it'll have a
it'll have a principality and then it'll
start to it the danger is that it can
start to to grow and to feed off
you know and you can see that like
especially as the morality of society
tends to break down
then you'll see that happen like in
amsterdam that's what happened whereas
in new york they tried to do the
opposite which is that they tried to
break down the kind of red light
district type places to kind of scatter
them
uh so now they're scattered were
scattered in the city they're more
hidden you could say they're not as
the city the city uh
you know um
places in new york are not as obvious
and not as as clear
and so it's different strategies i'm not
sure one is necessarily better than the
other
but uh you definitely will never get rid
of that stuff that's for sure
in the i mean in the new jerusalem you
know but that's about it
so the abc one two three four five six
three nine nine says i asked vander clay
about with the symbolism of icons and
saints holding their hands over their
chest area
and he chewed me out and told me to ask
you
that's hilarious i love i'd like to see
that i would have to see what you mean
what do you mean their hands over their
chest area
like what what like this
that
um usually this like there are a few
icons sometimes that will show this
you'll see uh somewhere of egypt
sometimes does this uh usually it means
that they're not worthy if that's what
you mean but those are rare there's not
a lot of icons that do that so i'm not
sure
um
i'm not sure what you mean
yeah
so that's usually what that means
all right so samuel ramilera says hi
jonathan could you explain how did the
navigations and the discovery of america
change challenge the medieval symbolic
thinking thanks from brazil
and so i think that it probably wouldn't
have had to and i think it in a way it
really didn't
because
the idea that like i mean it did in the
sense that people hadn't completely
understood that there was a land there
west some some people seem to understand
that for sure the vikings knew that
america was there
and uh so there were probably some
navigators that knew and probably even
in britain there were some navigators
that knew you see some of the legends in
some of the saints stories you see this
idea that there's land that way on the
west
but
i think that
the idea that it's a wild land is
something which was just inevitable in
medieval thinking the idea that the west
was where the amazons were right the
amazons and then all these wild uh lands
and what appeared to us as being wild
people you know i think that this is
something which was just a continuation
of uh
of uh medieval thinking
you know um
it was mostly the idea of like the the
weird idea that they would end up going
east right that they could flip the
world like they could go west to go east
like that's interesting
in terms of
like let's say the material world and
scientism and the idea that people would
find meaning by digging in the ground
right that they would find meaning by
by developing this technology and this
science that somehow it would uh it
would elevate them and give them more
meaning i think that that's interesting
for sure um
right so anthony rosa says related to
samuel's question where does south
america fit in universal history
it seems like it contains lots of
extremes plus catholics and wild
cardinals etc
well wes i mean
north and south america are the are the
end of the world right they're the west
they're the west of the west
and so they will end up containing more
extremes in them
but what's interesting about the
extremes like i always talk about
california a lot because i think
california is just such a great symbolic
symbolism happens place
because it ends up it doesn't end up
manifesting extremes in the way you said
so on the one hand
what you'll find in south america will
be
the last the last bastion of catholicism
will be in south america
way more than in europe that's for sure
but like you said it'd also have
all the weirdness of excessive carnivals
and also
weird hybridization of of the tradition
as well like the whole pacamama thing
and all that stuff
um
so that's america california's like that
too right california has the all the
wild stuff and all the crazy stuff and
all the hollywood and the porn and the
rock stars but it also has
the monasteries and the trads the
catholic trads and all these people are
there
more than in other places so
yeah
that's interesting
all right um let's see frederick gopher
schmidt asks what is in speaking in
tongues about
so
the thing about speaking tongues is that
i think we don't totally understand what
was going on back then completely
and so because of that we're confused
about what it is
um
so there's a sense in which
in in the scripture my understanding is
that there are two aspects of the
tongues one is speaking a language
which is understandable to others and so
it's like speaking in a way that
strangers can understand you that seems
to be one aspect of speaking in tongues
and then the other seems to be more like
being able to speak a higher language to
speak the language of angels
um
and so those see to me seem to be the
two parts of speaking in tongues
but now what we have with speaking
tongues is just like
i don't know what it is like the the
kind of pentecostal speaking tongues
just seems like a lot of chaos like
people just
sprouting like going into trances by
you know
i i don't question the experience i
think the experience is
is real i don't think anybody's
pretending but it seems to be people
able to kind of fall into a kind of
trance where they
they just utter sounds and they make
this this
they just make make sounds
sure it feels good i don't know i've
never done it i'm not interested in
doing that i don't find it very
particularly interesting but i have
heard some examples i even had a friend
of mine who who in the pentecostal world
said that she
at some point was received a kind of
weird blessing where she was able to
speak mandarin
and she for several years it just lasted
for a few years where she didn't
understand mandarin but she could know
she could speak it so it was as if
like if she wanted to say something like
a voice in her head would tell her what
to say and she would just say it and it
would be mandarin
and uh i mean i have no reason to doubt
her she's a serious person and not a
kook or anything so i a lot of weird
things are possible
you know
all right so christopher mihaly asks in
your talk with father kansas can you
explain more by what he said everything
needs a cross
that phrase has been stuck with me since
i first heard it
so i think that what he meant by
everything he's across that everything
needs a middle everything needs a place
a heart a place where the vertical
heaven identity meets with the
horizontal potential the horizontal
potential of its existence so it's like
you have the identity and you have the
potential and then you have the being
which finds root in the center of the
cross of the heart and i think that the
mystery that christianity offers is that
that center is also to a certain extent
across in the more colloquial sense that
is it's also a self-sacrifice
a self-sacrifice
moving up towards higher identities and
itself sacrificed down as a sacrifice
for its parts
and so um so i think that that's the
best way to understand uh understand
that
so the abc one two three four five six
seven or et cetera says when will you
complete your evangelization of stixx
and hammer 666. so i'm going to talk to
i think i'm he said he wanted he was
willing to talk to me in uh next year so
i'll probably write him a message and
try to set something up i'm very happy
to talk to him he's very intelligent and
not just intelligent but very
knowledgeable about especially
kind of western esotericism and all that
stuff and so i'm sure it'll be an
interesting discussion to talk to again
i look forward to it
definitely look forward to it so uh
i think we're done guys i think we're
done i really enjoyed this actually
i enjoyed being able to pay attention to
guys
and feel like i'm a little bit connected
with you
and so i would say thanks to brad and
lisa
and jacob who showed up as moderators
really appreciate it i wish everybody a
happy new year despite all the madness
despite all the craziness also we're
still in the season of nativity so
christ is born glorify him
and uh looking forward
i get the feeling like 2022 is going for
me is going to be about writing and so
because i won't be able to travel
because i will be more and more isolated
i will
write and uh
i also have opportunities to do so
writing finishing up the second part of
god's dog and the third part maybe we
could maybe do even two books in one
year that'd be awesome
and uh writing a book probably
that's what i want to do and so i just
haven't totally decided what book
exactly that i should write but that's
probably going to happen
in 2022 as well
um
and so thanks everybody for your
attention thanks for your support i
really appreciate it you know i
i always very grateful that you are a
part of
why i'm able to do this and why i can
continue to do this and why i have you
know
the time and the capacity to uh to to to
be involved so i i'll see you very soon
bye-bye everybody